We are live. Hello, this is Dr. Conner's for your next bed burst minute and with Michelle and Michelle, we had a couple questions, didn't we?
Yes, we had a great Zoom question come in the other day from a patient of ours. And the question is as follows, is it cancer in my body that is causing issues with my liver, adrenals and large intestine?
Or is it issues with those organs that are allowing my cancer to grow? Is there concern that more cancer is growing? Or should I just assume that these are health-related issues that need to be addressed outside of the cancer realm?
Oh, that's a loaded question. So really the question is, if I have, let's say, liver cancer. Is that why I'm having adrenal problems? Or is that why I'm having digestive problems? Or is that why I'm having issues breathing?
The answer is, if I have liver cancer that's contained in the liver, is that going to cause digestive problems? Well, indirectly, yes, because your liver adds up feeding to, you know, your liver is detoxified and the detoxification products are going into the small intestine in order to be gut rid of, right?
So there is some of that, but, you know, will my contained liver cancer cause adrenal issues? No. But can the emotions of having cancer are drained by adrenals? Yes.
So, in a sense, there's a separation of the organs, but in another sense, you're one bead, and even if it's not a direct physiological connection between the liver and the adrenals, there is an emotional connection, a stress connection that you can't separate systems, and you have to look at a person as a whole person,
and a whole bead, so there's both. There could be direct physiological things and indirect things. But the other thing you have to remember, too, is that just because we have a diagnosis of cancer, doesn't mean that I don't have Hashimoto's anymore, doesn't mean that I don't have adrenal stress anymore.
Doesn't mean that I don't have leaky gut issues that I still need to deal with. So let's erase the fact that you have cancer, and you would still probably have these other things that you want to deal with.
So I know that in a person's mind now that we get a cancer diagnosis, it trumps everything, and I also know, personally, that when you get a cancer diagnosis and you have another symptom, you tend to correlate it back to, oh, that's the cancer.
Oh, could that be metastasizing, or something like that, and all these fear issues come up of, I'm having trouble breathing, I can't get a good breath in, and we instantly think that we have metastasis to the lung, which can be true, and it's something you do want to address.
But sometimes we jump to conclusions where maybe I have some rib involvement that I need to go to a chiropractor or get adjusted, maybe I have a little virus, there's just a lot of other possible factors that we don't want to be too quick to jump to a conclusion.
So what you're saying is essentially, unless the cancer is specifically within one organ, like if it's in the liver, or if it's in the pancreas, or in your stomach, that the likelihood of it being the complete cause of symptoms that are associated with a malfunctioning organ is probably a little bit, yeah, is probably a little bit less.
Like if somebody has lymphoma, or breast cancer, there may indirectly, because we are approaching this from a whole body approach, there may indirectly be some interference with those organs, but that if there would be direct interference, it's probably not as much the case, because the cancer is in their rust.
That's correct. So you do have the interconnection of different organ systems, because physiologically they are basically speaking to each other.
But we don't want to jump to the conclusion that my lymphoma is causing my adrenal dysfunction, it's a little bit more complex than that.
So not that those things can't happen, but we don't want to jump just to that conclusion and blame cancer for every other symptom that we have, there's other things that we need to deal with too.
If we can just extend this out just a couple minutes further, we have had a couple of patients that are dealing with cancer in their pancreas, and that has actually caused some direct interference in like their digestion and blood glucose and things.
Can you maybe just quickly address that just to provide an example for how cancer directly in one organ can impact other bodily functions?
Well, sure, if you look at what takes place physiologically in that organ, so the pancreas is responsible for making digestive enzymes that are secreted and small and tested to digest your food.
And if I have a cancer that's growing in that part of my pancreas, I, in a sense, very real sense could have a decreased function of digestive enzyme production, that could cause digestive problems in itself.
So yes, the physiology of that specific organ is going to be diminished. So if I have cancer in my liver also, what does my liver do?
It does like 700 different functions, but most of those functions are have to do it detoxification. So my detoxification is going to be impaired because of the cancer in my liver.
And then I will have symptoms of toxicity and symptoms of lack of detoxification, and that could be, that could give a personal very wide range of different symptoms throughout their body.
Well, thank you very much for answering that, Dr. Connors.
All right, well, this was another member's minute, and we hope it was beneficial for you. Bye-bye.